[Music]
they are back at it ariana grande and
liz gillies reunite for the first time
in two and a half years gross don't take
gross i like robbie so go to the dance
with him no gross
yep the former victorious co-stars spent
some quality time together and liz gave
fans an inside look into their hangout
the actress shared a photo dump posting
a number of moments from what appeared
to be a much needed getaway but she
saved the best for last the final two
slides consisted of a video of her and
ari singing the song i'll cover you from
the musical rant
[Music]
and a selfie of the two smizing into the
camera liz captioned the post quote last
week the highlight seeing ariana grande
for the first time in two and a half
years it's like a beautiful amazing
thing ariana and liz have been close
since playing jade west and cat
valentine on nickelodeon's victorious
between 2010 and 2013. in 2020 they lit
up social media feeds with this
reenactment of a scene from the waterboy
and you are so cute
is there a girl you're seeing
seeing
i i i see a lot of girls
seeing
i i see a lot of girls
i see a lot of guys too although ari and
liz share a close bond a busy work
schedule doesn't always make spending
time together easy
last year liz opened up on watch what
happens live with andy cohen about not
being able to make it to ariana and
dalton gomez's wedding last may
something she was obviously bummed about
i could not get off of work to go to her
wedding because we would have to be
cleared for like seven days to fly so
not only could i not tell anybody but i
also couldn't even ask for the day off
and i couldn't get the day off oh my god
it would have been there but clearly
missing ari's big day hasn't affected
their bond
[Music]